good morning everyone um this is uh 15th
of January 2024 of the cabinet and we
start the meeting with asking for
apologies for absence do we have any
apologies for absence none thank you
very much and the second one is
disclosures of interest do we have any
disclosures of Interest to declare at
this for this meeting um councelor rock
first and then councelor W hins
afterwards uh in in respect of the uh
item on uh item four the Community
Medical Center up upper Lor which has
got uh implications for Primary Health
Care I am the vice chairman of St
wolston uh primary care practice in sand
I have um no executive control over that
practice and I should continue to be
involved and uh involve myself in the
decision on those on the advice of the
monitoring
officer and councilor W
hoggins yes I'm declaring an interest in
item cabinet item agenda item number
five in that my husband is the managing
director of a fuel Distribution Company
I am not a shareholder of the company
and nor do I have any role within the
company however I am not predetermined
and remain impartial and will take part
in today's debate thank
you
sorry um C yes from the oh yes we do um
we have apologies from Victor councelor
alock um yes we did we did have a note
from her this morning um that um she's
got a problem with her a medical problem
with her
leg right moving on we have the uh
minutes of the meeting held on the 4th
of December uh do we have any comments
to make on that and do we um uh
therefore councilor Rock uh I don't I
don't wish to seem like a pedant but um
the ward member for fenny Compton Parish
Council uh really should say the ward
member for fenny Compton really although
it's not it's not wrong but it would be
clearer I think so for minute okay if we
take that on board and with that in um
change in mind are we agreed with the
minutes councelor Curtis thank you
leader um I
mentioned recently in regarding the sill
spend
allocations that one of the Sills oh
gosh I'm
sorry the the name of the organization
should be the Shakespeare birthplace
trust it was incorrectly reported I
think Mr Buckland asked asked me to
raise that it should be the sorry David
do you have the details of that I don't
but I know that in the s report that was
considered on the 4th of December it
wasn't clear that it was Shakespeare's
birthplace trust and we will make sure
that is clear so thank you
chairman um can I ask for um a proposal
and a second for the minutes and can we
agree them uh councelor Curtis as as
proposing and councilor Gest is
seconding um all agreed yeah thank you
moving on uh we've got part A matters to
be referred to council there are none uh
Part B matters for decision by the
cabinet and the first one item is one
that comes under the deputy leader
councelor Rock it's the community and
medical facility at upper lighthorn on
pages 13 to
90 um well good morning uh this um is
been quite a long time in uh in
production there's there's quite a large
report attached to that and
um just a bit of background in that um
that set out in the
report I think most of it is uh
uncontroversial I imagine that um we do
have to uh by 106 agreement provide a
community facility in this new
settlement uh of significance
um what has caused a bit of controversy
is not so much that the basic provision
but our desire to support the community
in its widest sense which includes both
the police and the uh Primary Care uh
facilities for The Wider area
um it is our uh belief that doing as a
One-Stop shop gives best value for the
taxpayer if we can do it all in one uh
constructional unit I'm sure that uh Mr
Perks can help us more with the detail
of that uh the the the area that has
caused greater interest in The Wider
area there is a group of 24 parishes uh
in the east of the district that are
concerned about the overspill of Demand
on a primary care practices from this
new uh new
settlement uh and the phasing of
provision uh for a Doctor's practice uh
We've carried out many consult ations
and discussions both with the NHS
integrated care board and also involving
the Member of Parliament to Jeremy
Wright to pull all the interest together
with the result that we've now got a
joint report that um I'm recommending to
Cabinet um I think I'll stop there I
don't know if uh Mr Perks wants to add
any technical
details uh yes thank thank you councel
rock as um Council Rock sort of pointed
out to you there is a section 106
agreement relating to the new community
we're seeking to create up a light horn
which is partially constructed we're
reaching the point in that development
where the triggers for creating the
community center and the Health Center
buildings are going to be reached in the
sort of not too distant future um the
report examines a way in which we could
sort of effectively produce those those
facilities there's a commitment at The
District Council to be to be clear to
cabet the only commitment in the 106
agreement to the district council that
we have to meet is building a community
center what the report before you today
appraises and advocates for is that we
join with our sort of Partners at the
ICB and the police and produce a single
Community Building um because that's
economically more effective and we can
get sort of more value from the section
106 money um the recomendations in the
report strictly that that those are
Consultants report that explores um the
potential in a lot more detail I'm we're
seeking that that be
endorsed and the principle of working
jointly with the ICB and the police be
endorsed but before we would commit to
spending any money and commit any
expenditure of the council in a detailed
design we would bring that back to
cabinet so that cabinet can make an
informed decision before sort of
committing sort of any sort of budget
going forward I think that's a summary
of what we're presenting
today thank you uh before we move on to
the recommendations uh councilor Kum
have you got any comments you want to
make yeah we we did this specifically
mention this at um I on Friday um I'm I
you want the our update now rather than
the general one further on um yeah
there's several things about this on the
whole members were supportive in favor
of getting this underway as soon as
possible further delay but there were
queries about the time scals and the
logistics of the proposed Center I think
one particular concern was the fact it
was mentioned it could be fully
functioning uh by
quarter 4 25 26 I think it's 1.6 in the
report I do think that's probably highly
optimistic um so again would be nice to
have some sensitivity analysis around
that to see how feasible that is uh and
we don't want to raise expectations
unnecessarily whilst I agree with the
fact that we need to do as soon as
possible and if the 25 26 quarter 4 time
table is achievable and feasible you
know that could be loed but again we
would like to see some progress on that
uh perhaps come back to ourc to see how
that is going but on the whole we
support it the members were ke for the
outdoor space to be a feature at the
center if possible again for various
different reasons we think it's sensible
I know that Mr Perks
mentioned the ICB had two different
models when it come to the actual
renting or how it was going to be be
done so there was some UNC certainty
about that uh and the group felt that
while some local GPS been consulted they
felt it'd be beneficial to ensure other
GPS were able to respond to the
consultation as obviously there some
potential challenges around the release
of section 106
money uh and then also about about the
rent as well um Etc and potential
borrowing if necessary um so on the
whole generally supportive still lots of
uncertainty around it uh and whether
things can be done to mediate or
mitigate those
uncertainties um but yeah on the whole
support it but again we would like um a
further report to perhaps come back Toc
with with the progress how things are
going and and whether other things need
to be done and and whether we the
partners are are meeting their
obligations shall we say uh thank you
I've got councelor cure and then I've
got bring in uh councelor Rock and if
necessary we can bring in and the
officer at the end uh so councelor
coucher thanks very much chair this is a
really important piece of infrastructure
that we need to build as soon as
possible uh upper Lorn is going to be a
very substantial settlement at the
moment without that it's putting
pressure on existing infrastructure in
other Villages uh around the east east
of the district so I I'm really pleased
with this report um but we need to
ensure that we really keep the pressure
on to do this as quickly as we possibly
can uh thank you councelor
rock uh thank you chair um indeed uh uh
it was discussed OC I thought that a lot
of good points were made and it was it
was a helpful discussion um in terms of
the time scale uh again I'll defer to to
Mr Perks I think he'll come ask him if
he can come in at the end he will
explain
RCs R ICS stages of build but um I think
you mentioned uh about get getting the
partners to be fully engaged with it and
um the the concern as I expressed at the
beginning throughout has been not the
principles as councilor CRA said that we
we do want to get on with it is how we
in involve ourselves with the um
provision of Health Care and and the
division between uh ourselves and the
NHS uh ICB what this does is sets out a
mechanism where we set the set the
ground out for them to achieve it now
the the point at issue here is provision
of the Health Service we can provide
them with the means the method that they
do it with and how they appoint the the
pro the provider for that is entirely in
their gift uh and um we have been
looking over the weekend
what it says in the legal agreement and
not only is it sensible that they they
provide it not the district council but
it would appear that it's it's bounded
in the uh in the legal
agreements in terms of Consulting with a
doctor's practices my understanding if
can Mr Perks can put me uh straight if I
got this wrong is we didn't set out to
consult with any of the potential biders
for provision of Serv Services because
that would would not be in our gift to
award that that's up to the ICB I
understand one or two uh doctors
practices did approach the consultant
and gave them their opinion unsolicited
whether that was useful um
it is a matter for those that discussed
it with them but that wasn't something
we set out to do that's a matter for the
ICB to to deal with um I I don't Mr
Perks wants to add any anything more um
do you want need to add anything at this
stage count
Mr well if it would help the cabinet I
can just quickly address the points that
um counc raised in turn and then we've
got um a view on those the the first
point was on the sort of deliverable
time of 25 26 just to be clear so as
cabinet are aware of that that that
would be the best possible outcome based
on the program of the time that it would
take to facilitate the building um in
reality that will be determined by a
number of factors for example there are
triggers in the section 106 based on
occupancy so we won't get the money
until a certain number of houses have
been built which is at the whim of the
housing market so that that figure is
sort of if we started today when could
we get it finished the the more delays
in the start the later that'll be but it
was just give indication on that
um in terms of outdoor space um part of
there's a village design statement that
sort of accompanies this that deals with
the community facilities at upper Li
horn generally that Village design
statement would allocate us a site on
which we can put the the the the
building whichever building that we we
go with um we've commented to that that
we would like outdoor space so we've
tried to pick that point up um in terms
of the GP models there are two sort of
models for financing GP practices either
sort of public finan broadly or or
private finan by the GPS the purpose of
this report is to identify whether the
council have an appetite for helping the
ICB produce a building so that will
steer their appointment of the GP um
and as I think councelor Rock has
pointed out it's for the ICB to appoint
their their preferred GP for the
practice and as we move to the detailed
design stage we would certainly want to
work with the appointed GP um to make
sure the building sort of meets their
needs and I think the final point was
could we sort of give progress reports
to the scrutiny committee which we
obviously be happy to
do and um I think
you sorry councelor Crump yeah most that
didn't make sense and it's good te that
cancel Rock's acknowledgement of the the
good points at osc must have a good
chairman chairperson um no I identify
chairman as Ry by um certainly I think
we need to make sure that we are not
giving unrealistic expectations and like
you said we are under a lot of pressure
um from the residents and the other GP
surges are under a lot of pressure
because this isn't going on and I
appreciate the fact that the ex
106 money is conditional on occupancy so
that's not unreasonable but we've got
you know I would have pret tentially Lo
to seniors chairman scy that the 1.6 was
strengthened to be show how realistic
that was because I think we are giving a
maybe a slightly false impression that
it's going to be achievable by March
26 and I don't think that's fair yeah I
can understand that you know with the
with the following when going downhill
it could happen but I think we need to
be slightly more realistic about this so
apart from that I've got no issues at
all uh I think it's um we need to take
note of 5.1.3 which says a
pre-procurement report will be brought
back to the cabinet for approval of the
detailed fully costed project before
procurement of the design and build
contract is commenced so we will see
more uh more of that detail at at that
time councelor rock uh yes I think it
might be helpful uh to note in the
minutes uh that the osc's feedback on
that point uh it it does say we estimate
a fully functioning facility can be
achieved by that as uh Mr Perks has said
that is on the basis of um standard
deliveries and
uh some form of Words which uh Mr Perks
can agree with the committee Clarks
could explain that that uh to to
moderate expectations as the chair
chairman of the scrutiny committee
suggested could well be
useful so okay but we've reached the
point when uh we have a set of
recommendations in front of us um the
recommendations are on um on on page 13
uh that the report attached at appendix
one be endorsed that approval is given
in principle for the undertaking of a
joint project with the NHS comry and
warshire integrated care board and
warshire police in line with the
findings in the report attached at
appendix one and note that further
details of the project will be brought
back to the cabinet at the conclusion of
the reer stage two for approval prior to
a design and Bill contract being
procured and that the deputy chief
executive in consultation with the head
of Law and government a monitoring
officer be authorized to enter into any
legal agreements required for the
implementation of the recommendations
above um do I have a proposer I have
Council Rock as a proposer and uh any
and councelor coucher as the second are
we agreed to yes we are all agreed thank
you very much
indeed moving on to the next item which
is comes um under two portfolios one is
the as starts with um under my portfolio
as uh for um climate change uh but uh
the implementation is with councelor
grot as the uh chair of as the portfolio
holder for environmental and um
Neighborhood
Services and just to give you some
background to this um I was um
introduced the original climate
emergency in
2019 and chaed the U task and finish
group uh which came up with the
recommendations that the council had to
act on climate change and to do so uh as
uh soon as possible but obviously with a
a a final date of about 2030 I think it
was adjusted to in the end um so in
order to tackle uh climate change and
air quality uh we're investigating the
use of HBO for Waste vehicles in our
district District which can reduce
carbon emissions by by up to 90% And
also reduce particulates that affect air
quality uh so the this the climate
change um decision envir was was uh in
201920 uh before this Contra new
contract uh was uh uh decided and
implemented uh before the final decision
on the use of HBO is implemented we have
to negotiate contracts um and standards
conditions and standards as well as the
price with our contractors certification
and guarantees that the product is
genuinely from waste materials and
Supply by reputable company is key uh it
also has to be part of a transition plan
uh because we have to start thinking
about when long range electric vehicles
are available uh and uh achievable uh
all other sustainable renewable fuels
are available then we have to start
thinking about those but we we the
contract is where it is at the moment
and uh so we have to do this in stages
I've investigated some of the councils
that are already using HBO and they
cover a quite considerable number of
councils run by all the main political
groups and include many that are
conservative run as well as labor and
liberal Democrat run and and those that
are not nonone um they include East
Sussex District Council Hein bur bur
Council Northwest leerer District
Council blaby District Council test
valley B Council faren B B Council those
are the conservative run ones and then
labor run Hackley Council and liberal
Democrat run hinley and bodsworth bur
Council and South Cambridge District
Council and I know there are many many
others that have moved on to
HBO South Cambridge has a transition
plan in place for the introduction of
alternative vehicles and it it's I think
that is something that a lot of the um
the professionals are beginning to start
working towards um making sure that we
do have transition um um over a number
of years now the council the waste
connection service is run by a
contractor and so that we do have to
have negotiations with that contractor
and the final price we pay will depend
on the discussions and the market at the
moment the price for HBO is lower than
the cap we've allowed in the budget um
but we need do need to negotiate a
longer term deal because that will
stabilize costs as you will aware there
is a conflict in the Red Sea at the
moment and the price of diesel is
currently rising in quite quickly uh and
inflation means that we've also got to
allow for other price Rises over the
next three years so we have to have a
cap on the maximum we're we're prepared
to pay um but if we can have those
negotiations we we might be able to
bring that down to a a more reasonable
level and over a three-year period uh
that's what we are we are doing it's
it's that's the that's the principle um
some small adjustments to the
recommendations are needed to clarify
the intentions uh of the cabinet
so a new uh some set of recommendations
has come forward and basically um they
make sure make sure that that the use of
appropriate appropriately certified HBO
as an alternative to diesels be agreed
subject to recommendation two and the
approval of the conclusions of the
negotiations in paragraph three below
and then the the number uh two
recommendation two is that subject to
the approval of the draft um 2024 25
Revenue budget The increased costs
arising from the use of HBO will be
built into the revenue budget for the
period uh
20242 to 2026 27 so that's the three
years Capt at a maximum of 250,000 per
year but that is a maximum as part of
the negotiations to be entered into that
the delegated authority be given to the
head of environmental and Neighborhood
Services to negotiate and conclude any
consequential contractual modifications
and or other arrangements necessary to
give effect to recommendation one and
the the negotiations will be done by the
department that fun falls under the
portfolio holder of councelor gr Groot
so I invite her to add her thoughts at
this point as this will move into her
portfolio thank you thank you leader yes
um in 20 uh 2019 2020 there was a
climate emergency declared by The
District Council and part of the action
plan was to be Net Zero by
2030 we also have a climate fund
and um you know a Provisions been there
to make sure that we move this Council
forward to make to reduce our carbon
footprint the uh Fleet for The Refuge
Vehicles is the largest contributor to
our carbon footprint at the moment and
this is one easy one very effective way
of um fulfilling our commitments to The
Climate emergency and to the Clean Air
for our
residents I think also it is um a way
that we can you know demonstrate that as
liberal Democrats we are you know
actually making good on promises to
implement changes I mean because
obviously a fund a climate change fund
is very good but if we have just have it
just set to one side and never used it's
a bit like a Fab egg you know sort of
it's just very pretty to look at so we
are very keen to move those principles
forward however we do have um very
obvious commitments to our residents and
the you know to make sure that we are
pay you we are using the you know
hardworking taxpayers money as wisely um
as
possible so I'd like to propose this
um this uh paper to ensure that we um we
go we stand by our commitments in a way
that does not uh put burden on um
financial burden unnecessarily on our
residents currently our um Refuge um is
um is on contract and have a fleet that
has between the two District councils
over 66 wagons the um Refuge um contract
was renegotiated 2021 so you know a way
you know ideal way would be to be
looking at a fleet which is completely
not carbon neutral whether that be
Electric Vehicles fuel cells this sort
of thing but at the time that the um uh
contract was negotiated this was not the
most coste effective um way of um
implementing and of course the Practical
issues of a very very large District we
made the choices there and we are where
we are the thing is though the um
shortterm use of HBO allows us across 66
wagons that we have across the um the
two District Council which cost 100,000
I believe from my 100,000
each yeah thank you yes 140 oh 140 sorry
thank you this allows us a way to
fulfill our
obligations without having um you know
any um any obsolesence in the fleet or
upgrades which could cause um know sort
of expenses onto our um our residents
so this is why I mean of the options
available to the cabinet we see here
that option one is to agree that um the
district uses HBO in its Refuge
collection vehicle Fleet instead of
diesel and this is built into the draft
Revenue budget from 2024 onwards for as
a maximum of uh £250,000
um for the for three years
i' would like to um support this
because this means that the we have the
climate fund which is been dedicated to
looking at things such as
um updating the
fleet um and we can you know in a more
long-term effective way the most cost
effective way without the um the time
pressure on us for to do things um
immediately and we can also um use
consultation from bodies such as cic you
Center Excellence for low carbon and
Fuel Cell
Technologies and review of the fleet by
Energy savings trust to make sure that
the the carbon sorry the um climate
emergency fund is used for that um for
that option um in the meantime um so
that's why I prefer option one over
option two option three um no we can't
just do nothing at the moment we want to
make sure that the um um that our
children um and our residents have clean
air and um you know we contribute to um
the climate emergency I mean um and also
the there is an argument to be made for
offsetting the um carbon footprint um
using carbon offsetting but obviously
that has its place but in certain issues
it could be sort of seen as as
greenwashing so that's what um I think
I've covered everything I like to ask
this so thank you
chair I have um one person to who um
proposed it that's councel Rock I think
you said you were proposing I think
councelor no was it who is it those said
that they were
proposing councelor grup that's um we
need a second and then I can bring in
other people um counselor um Co has
seconded it I'll bring in other uh
people that want to
contribute okay anybody else that wants
to contribute at this
Point Council W hoggins I'll bring you
in now then
please yeah I'd like to wait for the
debate as I said I was impartial for the
for this I I'll wait till others have
spoken thank you okay councelor
passingham and then councelor
Crump well yeah I'd like to make a
statement on behalf of the green uh
group uh we appreciate the effort and
money uh will be required to reduce the
carbon footprint of the district council
we are in a climate emergency in action
is required now we have considered the
use of hvo to power The refug Collection
Fleet and conclude that as a stepping
stone this is a reasonable step we note
the importance of using fuel fully
compliant with the Department of
transports renewable uh transport fuel
obligation we also knowe that whilst
tailpipe emissions from hvo are only
modestly improved over deal diesel
fuels by moving away from fossil fuel
net CO2 emissions are dramatically
reduced we do think it's important to
review the policy after a year the
long-term Solutions l in government Le
legislation for a circular economy big
reductions in packaging and incentives
to return bottles aluminum Etc uh will
prevent the excess of materials entering
our waste and recycling streams this
leads to less frequent Journeys the
lighter refuse collection lower cost for
counselors and residents and brings
forward the opportunity for electric
waste collection uh even in rural areas
thank you very much indeed and um just
um just to you know to to update it the
government has now issued its biomass
strategy um fairly late but they have
have done that one uh that's of interest
uh we're still waiting I think um um we
are wait still waiting um maybe Julie
Lewis can confirm for the updated
resource uh strategy I think from from
government uh that yes that's the case
uh and both of those will be of ke key
part of um this this the next two to
three years um we we do need to tackle
exactly as you say a whole rap gamut of
things including um use but uh as
somebody who used to work in circular
economy I said fully endorsed the whole
idea that we we should be working and
thinking in that will be in that way
councelor um councelor Crump you also
want to come in yeah thank you uh leader
um certainly I've got whil I toally
understand and get the principle where
we come from looking at the report I
think it's rushed we've had a change in
the recommendations on the Sunday
afternoon which is not good you know um
lots of people would have already had
the cabinet papers um and they would
have had the original recommendations
and whilst I acknowledge it's happened
in the past in the previous
administration we know we the admin your
Administration is pring itself on being
different um but unfor
there's no difference there and I am
disappointed that we had to tease out
the recommendation for three years
capping from CC the curses who helpfully
intervened on Friday um but then that
was disappointing so it gives the
impression it it was rushed and there
are other reasons why I think it's
rushed if you look at the options on
paragraph 2.1 we've got option one
option two option three and option four
has mysteriously disappeared now it was
either such a good option or such a bad
option it was taken out and again this
is poor this is slap Dash I'm not you
know this is shouldn't be done if we're
having the information and again I would
have criticized the previous
administration for this because I am a
numbers geek and I can just about count
to one to five I use me fingers so that
is poor so and then just going back to
the report
um it's good to hear and Council gave
some uh reassurance on Friday about the
other authorities particularly the
biffer ones that are using these
vehicles using this alternative fuel but
it would have been good to hear about
that or read about it in the report and
to see what lessons those contractors
had learned from doing it so then we
wouldn't be get an impression that we
were going early or the the report seems
to give the impression we are going
early but there's nothing in the report
to say that other authorities are are
using this and it came from the head of
service some reassurance that other
buffer organ um buffer contractors are
using this so I think that needed to be
made clear the pros and cons and what
they what their experiences
were then I'll go on to my numbers Geek
Side the details approximately an extra
96,4 per anom you know um obviously
there's some calculation there because
nobody would suddenly come out with 400
on the end of 196,000 If there some
calculations even if it was Inc
confidential it would be good to see
some of the details making up that
196,000 and then we could make us a
judgment on how sensitive these costings
are to inflation we've already ker
Junior already spoke about the Red Sea
and the issues with um the volatility of
the prices so it's not particularly
clear there um and there's also what
experience is that if more and more
councils and contractors are using this
will that inevitably increase the price
and again is there sensitivity so I
think that's one of the other issues
I'll tell you I've I've I've s got me
grumpy head on right on today um
1.1 you talk about the a longer term
fixed price
deal um to get a better right but again
there's a that's a bit contradictory
firstly to one of the recommendations
where you're looking at it for three
years and then on 1.1 is therefore
proposed that a
review of the use of hoo will take place
on an annual basis
so you might be able to review it after
a year but if you're in a fix term
contract for 3 years to get a better
price how can you go out it is there
something built in um so I think that's
one of the other issues I've got
concerns about as well
so again bottom line I've got no problem
with the principle behind this but I
think it's rushed there should be more
detail in terms of costing there should
be more detail in terms of who using it
where and what their experiences are
because that would be sensible and then
it won't give the impression that we're
rushing in into this that you've you've
looked at it you thought about the
experiences of other other
contractors and again just this other
final bit I might as well I've started
so I might as well end me ranked on
5.2.2
[Music]
um the recommendation goes for about 3
years is but the financial implications
are done over five so again that's a bit
contradictory and it doesn't say much
and the revenue cost of The Proposal is
a big range from 150,000 to
250,000 and I don't know why 150,000 was
chosen because we've already said
19641 point1 one so apart from that it's
a good
paper thank you thank you so much um
before I bring going councilor W hoggins
um can I just say the research that I've
done uh on the councils um I think ham
District Council which it um was also
District um conservative run at that
time was one of the first ones they went
in 2019 to 20 uh most of the rest went
in 2020 to 21 um so actually there was
quite a number of councils already
running um with this as a as a a
methodology before um you know before we
um U move forward so one of the things
that um I I think we're going to
undertake is to make sure that uh we are
many of those have their own waste feets
but some of them are biffer uh have
biffer as the contractors or other
contractors where there is a particular
Council that has a uses biffer as the
contract we will make sure that we are
um lazing with that but this is not a
New Concept that they have been councils
running this uh with this as a principle
as a as a a method um using HBO for
quite some time um
one of the things um that I mentioned at
the beginning and the there was a recent
green Alliance uh paper um which noted
the potential of biofuel Blends and you
can blend it as well you it doesn't have
to be 100% you can blend it if you are
if if um required and it is worth noting
that current diesel already has to have
a blend by law um but the government
already has to have say a blend I'm not
sure what that blend is but it is it is
from a bio uh Source biofuel source
Source um and um they they noted the
potential of the P biofuel blends to
reduce tailpipe emissions uh in cases
where electric vehicles and other
alternatives are not yet viable uh but
of course they are moving forward quite
rapidly and it but the the key
conclusion that they made was that
policy makers should interject to
promote electric vehicles uh and the use
of biofuel made using waste stating that
this would bring benefits in terms of
life cycle emissions food security and
food fuel cost for consumers and it is
mentioned in the in the government uh
biomass strategy that we need to move
forward much more um on on this one so
uh I think this is something that uh uh
we are we are lagging we have actually
behind many many other councils and we
have to catch up with them thank you
councelor Crump and then I've got
councelor W hogin just about again I was
emphasizing the fact that no problems
with the principle but we will you to
use your terminology cancer unit detail
in this seem to be lagging
we've you know the fact that you've got
this information the fact you you know
about it and you spoke passionately
about all these different contractors
and councils have done it it would have
been good to have that information it
would have been good to see their
experiences it would have been good to
hear issues whe they've had any issues
regarding Supply and fluctuations in
price and again the the costing could
have gone in um the blue papers so we
got some but again so basically I'm
supportive but there seems to be a lack
of detail which would make us easier to
scrutinize prac and most of that will
come back with the um under
recommendation three because
recommendation three does say that
delegated authority is given to the head
of environmental and Neighborhood
Services to negotiate and conclude any
consequential contractual modifications
or other recommendations necessary to
give to effect to recommendation one so
that is the that is the uh stage
um when you will hear all that
information coming from this is to start
the process and make sure that we start
the negotiations with the with the
contractors councelor w h
hoggins thank you councelor junor um my
first question really is who wrote this
report for presentation to all of us who
who was the author of this report also
I'd also like to go back to what
councelor grot said you said about your
you you mentioned about your commitments
to Residents actually what the lib dem's
commitments to the residents seem to be
to us is that you're going to increase
the green bin charge uh by2 pounds and
uh looking at the budgets you're also
going to increase uh their council tax
by5 PS for this for this District
Council uh changing the use of our waste
disposal Vehicles will not affect the
Clean Air of our residents in this
District it is absolutely
Preposterous to to allege that the
climate fund fund could be used to
mitigate the misery that is being caused
by global warming within the district we
could be more proactive about doing
about doing that I'd also like to go
back to what councelor councilor Jun had
alleged which was the diesel has has
increased uh exponentially uh due to the
recent conflicts in the Middle East uh I
have no evidence for that and I would be
welcome to see uh about these uh
increases the dramatic increases uh that
were that were mentioned uh that is not
my understanding of the price of of
diesel recently we have seen increases
in diesel prices and availability of it
uh in within the last 18 months but
certainly that is not a current uh
matter uh that should be of
concern um when the vehicles that were
take the the new vehicles for the waste
disposal contract were bought I was
utterly delighted that we were M ensured
that our our vehicles were using Euro
were Euro 6 engines it was a real TR for
this District that that that that was
that that was what we were that we were
going to to use um the thought let me
tell you now that the thought of
electric vehicles or electricity
batteries being used to power to power
um hdv Vehicles is never going to happen
it will make Vehicles so heavy that our
roads cannot take them that will not
that will not happen um I'm also very
concerned about the accuracy of the
calculations um regarding the the Caps
that are being put allegedly going to be
put in place here they can't be uh we're
looking at a very moderate increase uh
year on year with the figures that we
have before us and I'd like to thank
councelor shenton uh for doing this for
us uh 250,000 pound cap perom is is
overly optimistic the the the price of
um hvo is likely to increase
exponentially because there is just not
enough competition in the market
councelor bromich has sent us all an
email outlining his very grave concerns
regarding the production and
certification of hvo and I'd like to pay
particular thanks to him that he has um
along with myself really looked into
this matter the certification process is
deeply flawed it's so flawed that now uh
the European Union is now looking at it
it's basically self-certification they
just have to tick a box and say yes it
was palmel production will increase
increase as demand for hvo increases and
we all know what that means it will mean
deforestation on a very very high
scale so the political leader of the lib
Dem sir Ed Davy has been quoted many
times in this chamber and Ed Davy now
sits at the political heart of the most
shocking Scandal of our time wait one
moment please but let me tell you don't
know you will listen because I am
speaking but let me tell you that the
facts around H I will wait it's not
disgraceful it's a statement of fact but
let me tell you that the facts around
hvo production and certification have
the potential to be even more shocking
the libdems craved power SDC and this
proposal shows that you really don't
have a clue how to exercise it properly
now that you've got it to adopt hvo
would be a reckless decision of the
worst kind and will'll leave this Leb
Dem um Council exposed both financially
and
morally um thank you very much indeed
councelor Wally hoggins uh we attempted
to have a logical and rational uh debate
around this and to gather all the
information that we want and that is
what we will continue to do um this is
not something where we U um we we give
into sort of r in ETC uh now please uh
especially when um I do understand that
there are countries around the world
there are companies around the world
there are companies there are
individuals whose income does rely on uh
fossil fuels uh and and you may have a
different view to the rest of us but we
are intent uh as um as a scientist
myself to make sure that I gather all
the information and then we take the
decision the final decision as laid out
in the um uh um in the um
recommendations based on the information
that we will get a as we proceed
councelor Rock would you like to come
in uh thank you chair well uh I'll put
my hand up to um to acknowledge some
some of the things of um councilor Crump
but um since then we've had a rather
let's call it passionate intervention
from the leader of the
opposition
um some of which I found defensive
however um that the fact is it will
increase the cost there's there's no
question about that nobody's arguing
about that and that is a political
decision if if you're not worried about
the climate well that's fine you can you
can be not worried about the climate but
the fact is this will reduce carbon
emissions in Stratford district and
there's no other way we're going to meet
the requirements of the decision the
council took which incidentally was when
the conservative and administration on
the on the uh the climate objectives of
making us neutral by 2030 there's no way
it's going to be without doing something
without the fleet it's just it's a
question of
what it's absolutely incorrect to say
this will not reduce particulates and
nox emissions it does you can argue
about the significance of it but it does
I'll then move on to um scrutiny
committee now I was I got to once again
flatter the chairman of um uh overview
scrutiny by saying what an excellent
debate was had on this subject at some
length and a lot a lot of good points
were made uh I'm slightly
disappointed that um he said we've gone
away and changed the recommendations as
a result of what of that debate that's a
commitment I made at the end of that
discussion
that whether I it wasn't what I meant it
was the fact that it was it was changed
after the meeting I know that other
meeting other recommendations have been
changed after the debate over inity so
if that was implied it wasn't meant to
imply that so anyway to carry on uh one
of the things that was said at that
meeting are you a listening Council and
I did say we are listening uh there will
be a de debate on Monday there will be a
debate no doubt at Council and and all
the all all members can be involved in
that when the budget comes up but um we
we did actually listen to that I have a
list of all the points that were made
some of which that you've gone through
um and uh
I think they were all valid points and
as as I said at that meeting and and I
think um Dave passingham has said today
that you know these these are not easy
decisions there is a balance to be made
and a decision to be taken people have
to take a decision and we're about to do
that
now in terms of this cost statford was
was was flooded last week lots of places
were flooded the climate we had the
hottest year on record that the world
has had last year um the cost of climate
change is absolutely unbelievable and
uncertain going forward something has
got to be done about it personally if
I'm going to spend 3.1 Pence per bin to
have it collected and it's going to
reduce carbon emissions that this
Council makes with the objective of
doing what the policy has already uh
been set out by this Council under the
conservative Administration unanimously
passed I believe the climate change I
would recommend we go for the these
points that are put out and it does give
us an opportunity to review it as he
said here we' we've got to make a start
on the journey which we're too late
already to have done that let's get on
with it
now um we now have had a good dis
discussion um we've had a proposal uh
from myself anybody seconding uh the
counselor uh Groot is seconding that uh
and it will move over now into your
portfolio uh for you to have a a look at
and come back and report back on um once
you've had the time to to you know look
at all all those decisions um councelor
w huggings we we've already had the
debate um no you haven't answered one my
questions and one of my questions was
who wrote this report thank you the the
the it is on there is on the top of the
um report the the lead officer but I
don't think that is um relevant at this
point um it's incredibly relevant and
I've asked a question within this
meeting as if I thank you the report
author is always said stated at the end
of of any report Tony perks is is the
report author for this particular report
that you've got in front of you
today I don't want to comment any
further than than that there's
sufficient information for cabinet to
resolve on the issue in relation to the
use of HBO today and as been explained
there'll be a debate at Council in
relation to the budgetary implications
on the use of HBO within the budget
going forward thank
you Marti
Reon chair may I just remind uh everyone
what it says in the Constitution the
chair presides at the meeting and if you
have decided that the debate is
addressed and all the questions have
been answered then you can move on uh so
we've had a a we had a a proposal on a
second we now put it to the vote what is
the consideration of the cabinet are you
agreed thank you very much indeed that
is agreed and we move
on the next item is uh the capital
budget monitoring uh and that comes
under the resources portfolio so I hand
that over to councelor Curtis uh to
address his concerns and uh give us all
the information that we need for the
capital budget monitoring Revenue budget
monitoring and then the revenue and
capital budget um going forward
councelor Curtis thank you chair um the
capital budgeting cap that's a good
start isn't it the capital budget
monitoring period 1 to8 it's very
largely factual information I'd like to
thank Nicola for rolds for preparing the
report the
appendices a breakdown of the summary in
table one and table two further
breakdown of that is found in the
appendix one um further details of
expenditure by service on the following
Pages um I'm just going to make a brief
comment about number one eam place um
having made this acquisition it is
important that the project is brought on
stream as soon as possible I've spoken
to Mr Perks about this and Mr borl you
know I would like to see it by late
spring early summer if possible when
it's completed the investment that we
will have made we'll see an annual
annual revenue Savings in the region of
around
105,000 on the cost per anom on the cost
of providing Ben breakfast
accommodation um that will repay the
conver the purchase and conversion costs
over a period of eight to nine years or
so so thereafter we will have a capital
asset so I think that it's a very good
um decision to buy that to purchase it
and to bring it on stream um happy to
take questions um but I don't I I have
nothing further to add to to my comments
um so it comes with
recommendations that um are outlined on
page 101 we can have a further report to
the cabinet or further questions to me
as the portfolio holder thank you chair
thank you very much indeed um councilor
Co the Ean place will come under yours I
don't know whether you want to add any
extra to what council of C has already
said um yes it's it's well in hand um
we've got meetings coming up soon about
the planning Arrangement and you know it
is our desire to get it up and running
as soon as practically possible thank
you thank you very much indeed and say
there's quite a few um Capital
expenditures on uh page 102 uh and uh if
unless we've got any particular comments
to that have been made by anybody um I
propose councelor Curtis would you like
to propose the yes I'd like to propose
the paper uh the recommendation as
stated on page 101 I'm happy to second
so uh are the cabinet agreed to that
thank you uh so we now move on to
councilor Curtis's second paper which is
the revenue budget monitoring uh C I
will be thank you chair I'll be fairly
brief on this as well um update the
council as it says on page 117 like to
thank Jessica for preparing this report
um one comment I will just make again
happy to take questions on page
2.3 um the final bullet point uh council
tax those Eide among you uh referring
back to November may be alarmed at the
fact that this seems to have traveled in
this report but in fact there is a typo
in here the council tax it should read I
had this clarified this morning it
should read council tax totaling
67,5
4573 um an extra so yes an extra five
had got crept in there in error a a
dreaded um comma yes yes so um that's I
did say that take it's my report I'll
take responsibility for that typo
getting in there somehow or other
um I think that was the only particular
point I was going to make on that um oh
No Just Sorry a couple of others um the
estimated outter position November
reports showed estimated out estimated
Revenue reserve the 31st of March 2024
as 9,5
175,000 um the current report I'm
pleased to see has increased that out
estimated Revenue Reserve uh to
10,791 th000 so that's gone up about 1.2
million um as I say happy to take
questions but it's largely a factual
report um so I would leave it there for
now thank you chair thank you thank you
very much councilor Crump do you want to
say anything at on this point or not
it's it's just
um we have obviously we are looking at
the budget the task and finish Group
which are report briefly on as partly
overs in scrutiny it's it's just a
comment that we have spoken about before
that the re real big driver behind the
favorable is the investment interest in
4.15 at 2.2 million um so if we hadn't
had this 2.2 million faval variants you
know there could
been a reasonable uh short forall u
eight term position so um we all know
that there's several reasons why the
investment interest is is High um
because of higher interest rates
slippage and also the balances we've got
so but once we start spending the money
once we start the interest rates going
down and when we have that slippage
there's potential L money to invest on
the balances so therefore the interest
uh investment interest is likely to fall
significantly so therefore
it's
just to be aware there is a potentially
at the
moment the the figures will have to be
looked at once this investment interest
falls back to what we used to call
normal levels shall we
say
coun David Buckland wants to comment but
councelor Curtis also wants to I'll
defer thank you councilor Kum yes um I
think it's a very important point that
you make and thank you for raising it um
we have because of the the recent very
very high interest rates yes there has
been a significant variable VOR fa
favorable variance in the income from
that stream however um Mr B section1
officer has made it very clear that that
is we are treating that as a one-off it
is not built into the revenue budgets
going forward Mr B would you like to add
anything to that
no nothing further no I think you've
clarified it you we're not relying on
that Inc going going forward in the med
term Financial
strategy um Mr band yeah thank you
chairman just to comment that a number
of the reasons for unfair unfavorable
variances within the report relate to
cost of inflation at the moment and of
course the government is well Bank of
England using interest rates as a
measure to bring down the inflation so
whilst absolutely accept there would be
an unfavorable variance if it wasn't for
the increase interest that's being
caused by the inflation which and
therefore when inflation is brought to
to to more normal levels that would see
a reduction in the interest rates as as
well so they are linked the The
council's increased costs are linked
also to the council's increased
investment
returns thank you um are you proposing
that coun yeah I'm just back on that
just fact obviously usually there's a
differential between what we Pate in
terms of inflation and what returns we
got so when they fall the the interest
return turns will fall more
proportionately than the actual
expenditure so yeah so I accept your
point but it is not as clear ctis is
we're making that so thank you councelor
Curtis are you um moving that
recommendation anybody happy to Second
Council G happy to second that one uh
are you all agreed to that report and
the recommendations thank you moving on
then to the uh revenue and capital
budget uh which is the background and
assumptions and proposals that will be
forming the council's draft revenue and
capital budgets for 2024 25 uh onwards
um and this will enable a consultation
process to start with public local
businesses stakeholders and elected
members councelor Curtis is over to you
thank you chair um I'll speak a little
more on this report than the previous
two um the first thing I'd just like to
draw everyone's attention to is please
note that appendix one should should be
the FI the statement by the Chief
Financial Officer as tabled and the
correct version is online and um thank
you Council just for drawing my
attention to this on Friday so this is a
lengthy and very important report and
I'd like to thank Richard bar 151
officer for the diligence with which he
has prepared it I won't go into all the
detail it's very comprehensive and I'm
sure all members would have read it with
care before I cover the proposals in the
draft budget I just just like to draw
attention to a couple of
sections um the medium-term financial
strategy the mtfs has been updated to
bring together all the aspects that
impact on the council's revenue
expenditure and income and that is shown
in appendix
2 or appendix 2 two as it were recent
inflation has been extremely high
causing real hardship for many of our
residents in future it is expected to
fall and the figures in section 32 of
the report I did clarify this with Mr
Burl and they are based on government
forecasts those inflation
figures based on the working balance
Reserve assessment which is a sorry
there's lots of appendices here appendix
7 page
226 is section1 officers advice that the
working balance Reserve at the end of
the current mtfs should be no less than
3 million and as seen in appendix 2 page
147 taking the risk in into account the
balance is projected to be £3 m79
th000 looking at the proposals
themselves it's of course Salient to
note that public sector finances remain
very challenging since 2013 funding to
local government has been slashed by
50% the external environment is very
volatile which could affect both our
income and our costs the LGA estimates a
funding Gap of4
billion and the struggles of our
colleagues around the country to balance
their books are well
publicized we need to be prudent and
ensure we have adequate contingency in
our
reserves and this draft budget balances
the desire for Action Now with a change
needed to create a more cost effective
Council and protects our services for
the long term proposals include
resources to enable us to modernize ways
of working and to be more resilient at
the same time we propose continued
support for residents hardest hit by the
cost of living crisis and new
initiatives to help rural communities
and vulnerable residents improve
well-being and to address the climate
emergency all
aspects um of this draft budget are of
course subject consultation all aspects
I just like to reiterate that and I look
forward to hearing the views of
residents and stakeholders in the coming
weeks on the following proposals I'll
just go into a few of them our is a
largely rural budget largely rural
District apologies and rural areas have
particular needs and this draft budget
includes 28,000 for Rural crime advisors
working with a community safety team to
tackle R Rising rural
crime £85,000 to maintain the UB buus
service which protects vital connections
provides the vital connection between
isolated communities and public services
£55,000 for a pilot scheme to introduce
customer access terminal terminals in
rural communities to enable face-to-face
communication with the district
council moving on physical activity is
important to our residents health and
well-being the draft budget includes
£25,000 for targeted leisure activities
for people with long-term health
conditions particularly in rural areas
and we are we propose reduce charges to
higher public playing pitches in
Stratford upon aen to incentivize
sporting activity and to support
voluntary Sports
provision the continuing cost of living
crisis triggered by the conservative
government makes life very difficult for
some in our community and the draft
budget includes £250,000 cost of living
support for those who are most
vulnerable to meet the rising cost of
Essentials urgent action is required to
meet the climate change emergency the
clue is in the title
so to help meet the council's agreed
Target of zero emissions by 2030 the
draft budget includes an additional
500,000 for climate initiatives for the
climate change fund of which an initial
sum of £100,000 will be available for
smaller scale actions such as Capital
Improvements to community
facilities as we've already heard
£250,000 perom over three years will be
all or may be allocated towards reducing
emissions from the waste Fleet the
decision will on that will be
evidencebased
and based on the results of our public
consultation whatever criticisms may
have been made of the papers today that
is our position that it will be an
evidence-based decision and it will
fully take into account our public
consultation
period the council plan just adopted in
December was developed in partnership
with our stakeholders and subject to
public consultation again detailed
actions will now be developed to ensure
we deliver on the
priorities for which the public voted in
May and resources are identified for
this
purpose as I said earlier Council
finances nationally are precarious and
whatever the political persuasion of an
incoming Westminster government 13 years
of
underinvestment of conservative
underinvestment in public services
together with the economic aftermath of
brexit wars in Europe and the middle e
East will make it difficult to plan with
confidence to deliver the services our
community
needs the change program proposed in the
draft budget will enable us to invest in
the changes needed to save Safeguard
against Financial pressures in the
future through new technologies
commercialization service improvement
stronger Partnerships with the third
sector streamlining existing Council
Services we will ensure we can continue
to deliver high quality cost effective
services for our residents we will take
an invest to save approach so Council
taxpayers hard earned money is well
spent and finally as has been mentioned
by councilor Rock the draft budget
proposes an increase to council tax of
2.99% for which an average home
represents just an additional I have 40
P but I think you've reduced that
councilor Rock but 40 P per month to The
District Council in summary members of
the cabinet this draft budget is clear
achievable and financial sound
financially sound it's focused on
delivering the services residents have
told us they need and importantly the
changes residents voted for last May but
it is a draft for consultation depending
on the views of those we are here to
serve I will bring a final version for
consideration by cabinet and
subsequently discussion at full Council
next month thank you very much I propose
this report to cabinet so we've had a a
proposal uh and uh I'll take a second uh
first and then I'll Mo move on to any
comments and councelor rock you're happy
to say second um councelor W hoggins you
want to come in at that
point yes just a comment really that
aren't too lucky to have inherited such
um such a robust budget that's giv you
such EXC with excellent and prudent
Investments are giving you these
fabulous reserves that you're now
enjoying but it is a little bit I'm a
little bit perplexed by this because um
you talk about council tax council tax
payers need to have their hard earned
money needs to be well spent we've
already discussed the hvo although the
debate was was ciled somewhat um but I'm
a little bit um you may be able to help
me councelor Curtis on on this matter um
you talked about the um the need for the
cost of living support and that you you
have identified parts of the budget
that's going to do that but with that
with the hand that giveth the hand also
taketh away because you are now also
proposing within this budget uh 3.5 page
136 uh that uh this year you will
increase the um
cost of the the green bin charges or the
green wage charges by an additional two
pounds and again the following year that
will be another uh2 I think that will
make it £188,000 that in addition to the
council tax you will be uh clawing back
yet more money from our uh Council
taxpayers or our residents in order to
I'm sorry in order to uh fund that I
wonder if you could explain the need
given the robust nature of your budget
while you're actually having to increase
the green the green bin charges over the
next two years please thank you
councelor ctus um I believe that this
was something that has rolled over but
you would like to perhaps uh explain
that certainly
um so the green waste
charge the collection of green waste
does need to be undertaken I think we
probably all agree that that is the
case it could be undertaken
free of charge in which case the burden
of collecting that green waste would
fall on all the residents in the
district perhaps those on smaller Flats
those with no need to have their green
was collected um and those may be among
the people in the district with possibly
lowest incomes so I think my personal
view is that although it it is it is a
service best paid for by those residents
who actually need to have it um rather
than it being a un Universal Serv or
taxed Universal if you
like and coun C just my other point on
oh sorry sorry leader um the the cost of
collecting the green waste has in fact
risen by I believe about
9% so this charge which is putting out
the the cost of residence of around 4%
is still well below the additional cost
of this Council and and I understand
that the contracts are already in place
um which so they they've already be they
were already signed and and sealed so we
have to have to work with those
contracts and the contractors that we
that were signed up to this uh this
scheme um what I would like to do is
perhaps U make sure that we um have um
we are using that green waste um in
future because I think it's already you
know it would be nice to know exactly
the use of it anerobic digestion for
example can be used as a a way of
turning into into biofuel uh for the
future and I think I understand that
that is being used and that that may be
something that we can have more
information about going forward thank
you any other comments that want to be
need to be made um each of the portfolio
holders has uh particular items that are
in the draft budget I don't know whether
any of you would like to expand in
particular and make any comments about
uh I know Council coucher had one item
that he wants to
raise chair um we are charged with
making improvements uh to the way in
which the council is run uh and I'm very
pleased to see that we are creating a 2
million pound fund there uh to
facilitate that because too many too
many words have been spoken in the past
and too little action uh now I think
we're actually putting our money where
where where our mouth is um clearly we
have had one peer review in relation to
my port portfolio area there um we know
that we want to better support Parish
councils um uh do ensure that we're
maximizing the money that we can get uh
for infrastructure in particular and
there's work to be done there and we've
got the money to do it the other item I
just like to to highlight is new homes
bonus which is just a a real problem for
us you talk compared with the the
interest rate bonus new homes bonus is a
more unstable area which this government
continues to do on on almost on an
annual basis we don't know whether we're
going to get that and that is basically
the only money that we get uh apart from
2781 106 and sill money to go towards
infrastructure um and to have it in such
an unstable situation is not helpful to
to to Council like
this thank you and and also we're going
to have a a corporate uh peer review
coming up uh and that will raise issues
that we will need to address but over
the next three years we need to make
sure that we are addressing and
improving all the services of the
council and that's what we are planning
to do um councelor gut I think it was
one of the items was under your
portfolio and then I'll bring councilor
W hoggins in oh sorry me first yeah okay
thank you thank you leader yes I'm just
wanted to clarify the commun Leisure
Community instructor um because you just
wanted to say this fits in with our new
council plan for the health and
well-being of our residents and looking
um after our residents and communities I
mean this is not just going to be used
for people with um mobility issues um
and um specific medical um um problems
in the area this is actually uh setting
out to support our rural areas and also
our parishes so this person will be
supporting as part of our active
Community strategy now we do work with
slm as um part of um to deliver um
Leisure and um in the center um in the
district but this will be actually um in
it'll be um building on in a
constructive way the work that's been
done by the Outreach um officers at
Everyone Active I me mean they have been
doing things such as like in shipstone
um and the town hall doing Pates and
warm hubs um they've been seated
exercises they've been doing teen
exercises exercise classes things you
know for people that can't necessarily
get to our five wonderful Leisure
centers in the area so this is really
part of our commitment to move out and
support our uh our Villages and our
rural areas to make sure that our whole
District benefit from the health and
well-being which can be measured in our
social uh value contract which we do
review with everyone active and also as
a as a um um as a council make sure that
we um support our communities not just
with token um you know payments to
certain bodies just to to do specific um
contracts this will be moving forward as
a um a plan and working with existing
commitments we have some such as the
live and local um moving pictures to
make sure that our Villages and our more
rural areas are feel it are get the full
benefit from um you know at the money
that they um pay in the um um in the
council tax and fill more parts uh you
and get benefits thank you I mean as
part of the going forward as well one of
the items in the budget is is um making
sure that we address the impact of of
using agency staff for example it has
come to the point now that um rather
than continuing to use agency staff um
to to deal with um loads of work it is
better value to actually have a a
revenues offic so that's coming in uh
and also um the one of the things that
my community uh appreciates is the fact
that there are to be some more rumal
crime coordinators so I do appreciate
that because we do need to work better
with the police uh to tackle often load
level but a serious crime that occurs in
all across the district and sometimes
some quite serious crimes that that I've
picked up while I've been away over the
over Christmas um so that is that is
information uh going forward uh has
anybody else got anything else that they
want to comment com councelor W
hoggins uh yes when we go to um the
council plan and change program I have
very grave concerns regarding the The Bu
budget management and I'm qualified at
the lack of the detail around this
massive chunk of uh the taxpayers money
forming part of this budget there is no
aim specific uh plans with success
criteria across the council plan um
there are no expected details of what
this is going to be and frankly could
should might are not terms that should
be Associated uh with a a budget set
aside of2 million pounds it needs to be
specifics it's it's just um you know
might use it for this but we the council
plan itself still lacks uh any success
criteria how anything is going to be
achieved within it h and therefore I I
put it to you that the 22 million pounds
uh of taxpayers money being earmarked in
this way uh is uh is called for very
grave concern about the management of
this Council thank
you um thank you the the climate change
fund was of course um has been ongoing
for some years and we now uh have take
got a an officer dedicated to that area
and who has done an amazing amount of
work uh and I'm sure I would like to say
say thank you to her and to C T Tony
perks for the amount of work that is
being done now on making sure that we've
got a proper decarbonization program
moving forward uh after many years when
we didn't have any particular actions we
we are now doing something uh on that uh
on the corporate plan uh we are having a
working group to make sure that we are
have a proper action plan on exactly
where that uh that money is to be spent
and that is again U will be reported on
as soon as we we've done that uh any any
other comments that we want to make
Council W hogins do you want to come
back in again on this one yeah just a
just a comment that we're nine months
into your leadership of this Council and
we still don't have that uh the full
details of your plan for this Council
we'll nearly be a year in by the time
you've decided how you're going to do
this and particularly how and spent 2
million pounds of that money
implementing it thank you um did I I I
note the uh reports that have gone
through the climate change panel and the
OV scrutiny and various other panels on
the uh the climate change initiative and
making sure that uh um the the comments
the um work being done on
decarbonization has been reported uh and
um we make sure that uh we will be
bringing forward all the action plans um
so can I we have had a proposal and a
second um what do we have agreement from
the C cabinet thank you very much indeed
moving on to the um housing and customer
services portfolio the contract for Fred
winter Center accommodation uh based
Support Services uh package could um we
have the um relevant portfolio holder
addresses on this one please thank you
leader this proposal uh the
recommendations are that we get
permission to enter into a contract with
spring Housing Association for services
to residents of the Fred winter Center
and other facility users there for the
period
2425 uh with an opportunity to extend
for up to 24 months subject to available
funding and that the contract award and
any subsequent extensions are delegated
to the head of housing revenues and
customer services in consultation with
the portfolio holder myself um
background is
that unlike other un uh supported
accommodation a contract wasn't
originally put in place between SDC and
spring at the time Fred winter Center
opened and there were a number of
reasons um of which there were many the
obviously this happened at the time of
covid and the disruption that it caused
to private and public lives um priority
of F off focus officers on the mer
potential merger with
WDC and um an overreliance on standards
set in section 106 which didn't
adequately support management
Arrangements
spring Housing Association are the lesy
and service provider and therefore we
seek to approval to enter into a
contract with spring rather than
requesting a general approval to procure
the service um the report gives the
details of the current arrangements and
whilst there is very close work with
spring on terms of survery service
delivery standards um stronger
management will be achieved through a
contract management to deliver specific
standards to which both Sid parties will
have signed up um so basically the
approval from this meeting will put the
framework in place to formalize the
existing Arrangements which obviously
are currently in
place I think we just need to reflect on
the importance of the Fred winter Center
to the community and the service it
provides to such vulnerable people and I
think it has some extremely good success
stories um it has been supported by all
the bodies that have been involved in
its creation and its running obviously
with a complex service with complex
needs there are complex issues but I'm
happy that they are being addressed and
um the contract we are proposing to put
in place will help us continue to keep
things going in the right direction
thank you Lita thank you the uh
recommendations uh the service was um
started in
2022 um but uh it did not have not has
not had a detailed contract for the
services that this was provided uh that
I think it does need to be rectified uh
and make sure that we we we've got
proper contractual Arrangements uh
therefore the recommendations are to uh
make sure that those contractual
arrangements are in place uh so the
recommendations are one and two um you
are proposing those councelor calls uh
happy to um second those anybody else uh
want to make any comments otherwise I
put it to the cabinet uh that we agree
this all agreed thank
you moving on then to the um migration
and Asylum update which is on pages 247
to
256 uh and um could we have um councilor
CO's address this
item thank you
leader um the reporting close provides
an update on UK migration outlining the
schemes that supported by the council
and following the migration and Asylum
report from August 22 and its October 22
update um the recommendations are that
the contents of this report and the
update provided be noted and that the
count progress on the council's 21-25
pledge be
noted um it is an extremely complex are
as I can imagine there are ve you all
imagine there are many streams very many
different layers of funding very many
different requirements again it is an
extremely vulnerable community and I
think we have recently recruited a new
resettlement officer who previously
worked for County and that will bring
additional expertise into the team which
will prove invaluable excuse me um the
pledge in appendix 2 will be reviewed
with County and other districts during
the year to ascertain what is realistic
and of course to
maintain reaction response to any
changes that come through from central
government um we have requested
comparative data from County so that we
can accurately compare performance and
understand different approaches and uh
this will be made available when it
comes back in due course um and of
course any changes to the pledge that
we've made would be back be brought back
for before cabinet for debate and
approval um so at the moment the
recommendations relate to the report and
progress against that pledge um and I'm
happy to propose that this go forward
thank you leader and and I'm happy to
Second it's um it's for information only
and um the report details the scheme's
currently active uh and shares our
performance against the council's pledge
so that's um you know going forward
councelor Rock I I just wanted to ask a
question if I may and possibly um
uh Miss om can answer the question um
it's it's an issue that arises in my
wood how do we get on with crossborder
issues um this is obviously is
addressing Stratford district and some
interaction with the county but uh I've
Got U somebody that falls into these
categories I won't go any further than
that for reasons of
confidentiality but um the children are
being educated in straford district and
the the actual um persons are residing
in rugby District it presumably we've
got some sort of coordination goes on
there do we at uh is that done at a
county level or it is yes the um the
districts all work closely with the
county there's a group that oversees the
um project within those five districts
um and and just monitors really the the
position across the boundaries as
well thank you and can I thank the
officers work on this it's very harro in
some cases I believe so thank you very
much thank
you um so um we've we've had the that
that those recommendations um are that
um that it is um noted and um we've had
a proposer I've seconded it are you all
agreed okay thank you moving on now to
the next item which is the um uh growing
opportunities action plan and again this
is councelor
calls sorry you're getting all tired of
my croak
um there has been some extremely good
work group work done across um voluntary
sector the various different councils
and there have been some extraordinarily
productive meetings and it's been a real
privilege to be able to sit there and
listen to the work that has been carried
out in these
meetings the meetings have produced
excuse me have produced with the help of
council officers a great deal of work on
behalf of council officers um to produce
this action plan because you know wishes
should transform into actually
delivering difference for our
residents
um It's the final part of this leveling
up agenda for the period
2325 and it provides targets for a range
of
objectives details of what needs to be
achieved who the target groups are what
we want to
achieve and the details are W within the
plan enclosed so my recommendations and
for which I am proposing is that the
action plan be for 23 25 be approved um
that an annual report to detailing
progress be made by all Partners in
respect to their assigned actions and
targets and that is received and
distributed and that the quarterly
performance monitoring
report Target CP 2B be modified to
reflect the new plan with quarterly
progress being reported to the cabinet
as it currently is for the social
inclusion statement
reports
um we
at the last meeting of the cabinet the
Strategic plan was recommended to
council and
approved um it was in response to the
leveling up agenda of the government and
it is the next iteration of the social
inclusion
statement um the plan as I said has come
out as a result of input of all the
partners and there are many in the plan
in the partnership and the County
Council all five districts within the
county have a similar plan but we are
somewhat ahead I leave I'm sure they'll
they'll be working to catch to keep uh
it it level um there is a lot of work to
do to deliver this plan and we will the
council will pay a huge part in enabling
and
facilitating keeping Partners on track
focusing on delivery because obviously
they are all having an enormous amount
of work to do as it is already um any
outstanding actions or outgoing work
have been incorporated into this plan
from the previous
sis um to make sure we capture the
necessary actions and nothing gets lost
in
transition um it's not set in stone it
if analysis and
consideration result in a suggested
changes to the implementation again we
will bring bring that back to cabinet
for note as part of the annual review um
and and it will be part of the
continuous performance monitoring as
part of the quarterly performance
monitoring
reports it's helpful that the plan and
incorporates a number of work streams in
one place rather than mean different
parts of different teams it enables us
to keep an eye on what is happening and
that things are actually being delivered
and it allows us and both residents to
see what is aimed for and what is being
achieved um it supports and is
complementary to the council plan and
therefore I would ask for approval for
these recommendation excuse me
recommendations to be given I'm happy to
second that because I've been attending
uh some of the um workshops U on that
have produced the action plan uh and
it's key to say that this is um a
partnership approach that has been taken
across the district council marishi
County Council uh other public sector
bodies uh and The Wider voluntary and uh
Community sector uh all have had a u
input into the into the workshops uh so
um I'm I was happy to uh second um the
the work that came from that anybody
want to make any other comments councel
w
and actually there's some very um
commendable items on this plan that you
that we' brought before us but um the
what I'm concerned about is that there's
a lack of detail and success criteria
within the plan here and how you will
know these are being achieved but most
crucially is how this council is going
to monitor the success and progress
through this thank
you um the progress will be the subject
of this second recommendation which is
that there is an annual report detailing
progress um made by all Partners in
respect to their assigned actions and
targets and that will be uh part of an
annual report but there will also be a
quarterly Performance Management report
uh with quarterly action plans progress
being made as part of the
recommendations uh those are firmly part
of the recommendations that there will
be quarterly and annual action plan
report uh progress reports being made
made uh to the uh to the uh action plan
from all Partners we have to be in touch
with the County Council and the
community and various other
organizations Council M Huggins yes I I
noted those of course but it's how
you're going to monitor the progress
before those reports are are published
how how you're going to do to do that we
don't see any details of of that and how
you're going to hold people to account
if if things are not are not progressing
as such thank you we have to work with
all the partners including the County
Council on that one in order to be able
to produce the the report back uh and uh
you know that so we have an officer
who's done a tremendous amount of work
and again um I I have got confidence
that we will be able to tackle some of
the issues that have been Arisen in here
uh and um you we w we will use a sound
evidence-based um reporting system and
responses um to make sure that we work
across all those all those organizations
uh so thank you very much indeed uh we
got had a a proposer and a seconder
there uh and U does the cabinet agree to
the recommendations thank you very much
indeed that is
appreciated the F the other item that's
coming is the planning and economic
development portfolio uh to to talk
about the year three shared prosperity
and Royal England Prosperity funding
2023 25 Pages 299 to 314 and this comes
under councelor
coucher uh thank you very much indeed um
this uh is obviously the the third year
of a program of funding and this is the
replacement funding which the government
has put in place to replace the old EU
funding streams of erf and in ESF which
many of us are very familiar with um we
have taken a fundamental review of how
we are actually uh spending or spending
spending that money and I pay tribute to
Mark won and his team um who've
undertaken that work and next year we
will be doing things slightly
differently from how we have done in the
past um there is a greater emphasis in
relation to the shared Prosperity fund
on skills and training and it makes um
eminent sense for us to work um much
more closely with the County Council um
who are the the main um training
providers and certainly the the host of
the skills hub for the county um to be
working with them and uh that they will
be um uh working also with the other
four districts in how we're actually
going to um uh allocate and use that
skills funding one area that we have
retained direct control over is the
capital uh fund because we want to make
sure that that is uh we maximize the
chances of that being spent in Stratford
District um and it doesn't migrate
elsewhere elsewhere within the
county um in relation to business
support um because it's so important for
business that we see
continuity um We are continuing with
some adjustments uh most of the streams
that we have uh funded this year which I
know have been uh well received by many
of the business organizations and
individual businesses who have who have
have benefited from that um and one
thing that we'll be doing in a much more
proactive
way uh this year is the rural fund where
we uh have have some unders spendings
this year through a lack of projects
coming forward and we want to work much
more closely with parishes with rural
parishes um with nfu and other
organizations uh C covering the rural
areas to to make sure that we maximize
the the benefit that we get from that
particular um that particular funding
stream so there are some clear
recommendations here um uh I've outlined
how we are proposing to change the year
three funding
applications um it is proposed that the
leader and the planning and economic
development portfolio holder continue to
decide which Grant bids should be
accepted having sought feedback from the
local Prosperity Advisory Group hpag
where the council continues to run open
calls itself and subject to
recommendation one that the authority
continues to be delegated to the deputy
chief executive in consultation with the
planning and economic development
portfolio holder to finalize
arrangements to mobilize the year three
projects
selected and are you making the proposal
for that recommendation uh I'm happy to
Second those proposals have we got any
comments that anybody wants to make uh
on any aspect of
that no no comments are we agreed then
to the the recommendations being moved
forward agree thank you very much indeed
uh we've got now the um issues arising
from the overview and scrutiny committee
and thank you count to uh to all
involved in that last
item thank you councelor Jun um yeah
obviously a lot of the debate was SED
around the hoo and also
um the um upper light on Heath Medical
Center um we did have a where we
interrogated ccel the grott and she Happ
to mention dep PES mode I've never been
to an osc before with uh deash
mode that was the one yes yes I could I
could see you as a young Dave Gan
councelor o so but not quite with the
with the blonde highlights so um no it
very informative um as as youest um
Council growup was was Grill quite a bit
and uh Council
Rock assisted and on a couple of issues
so that was helpful and and again I
think there was some
um need to explain the fact that um
around the recommendation and that
wasn't what was me so if if that was
came across like that it wasn't meant to
like that c rocks I do to apologize for
that a couple of things we talked about
it's good to hear that counts the Curtis
one year was there to give Clarity
around the the three years um for the
cap with 150,000 on the hoo which was
then brought into the actual um
recommendation um to make it consistent
um I know he's disappointed about the
lack of pond as well so apologies for
that but um C grow got improved for me
um but the real issue we were looking
for there's coule things to do with uh
evidence and clarification and and
counselor curses just mentioned it
regarding the budget um we've got a
budget task and finish Group which Kel
Johnston at chz and um their mind
concerns were Clarity around the2
million pound uh for the Council
planning change program which I assume
is not climate change it's all change um
so I think we clear and I think there's
some clarity around that um and whil
there's some explanation it's being set
aside for implementing the plan through
action points the action points and
areas haven't been confirmed yet so
detail is as much as possible at the
earliest opportunity would be helpful
you know I would be interested to see
about realizing our commercial
potential um obviously fundraising uh
externally from commercial organizations
Etc helps to keep the councel tax down
but it is a difficult Market to attract
income from you know I used to do that
as part of my old job fundraising from
externally so and sometimes the
additional fundraising or commercial
opportunities can be limited and not as
uh don't realize as much is and
originally anticipated so just a word of
warning on that so but I think this
there's some Fair points that ker
Johnson tusking forish gr raised another
Point related to the HR budget and again
kener Johnson quered whether this was
sufficient to implement the staff
strategy and for the increase in
apprenticeships and training that have
been proposed so we will be watching
that properly because obviously um staff
are our most significant and valued
resource so therefore um we need to make
sure if we're going to say they going to
have the training and the strategy Etc
we need to make sure the resources are
used wise
ineffectively um yes there was also
acknowledgement of the ecology officer
and the increase in plan enforcement
offices um so they they were relatively
happy with that
um and the only other thing that um we
raise the fact that the nextview in
scrutiny meeting we're going to have two
guest speakers who want a better r or
but are coming in uh so again we want
counselors to to give some information
or questions to be raised if they have
concerns you know obviously not all
counselors of some couns don't
necessarily have many social housing
particularly orbit properties so we'd
like to um make sure we're asking the
right questions at the right time and
then there will be um we spoke about the
far service
consultation um where I think cat G will
be responsible regarding the final
response from the county to the County
Council and the only other thing we
spoke about was the Victorian Christmas
Market which had obviously was very
successful but presented challenges
regarding cap traffic congestion
and as members we F A lessons learns
review a report back to the committee
later in the year just to see what went
wrong what could be improved who do we
need to speak because there were pros
and cons about it great for the economy
but there was also congestion
pollution somebody mentioned safety I
wasn't sure how much how how detailed
that was but again to to give it a
better um experience for for our
visitors to stford so I think that would
be good and I know the the head of
service already said that was in hand
and been working with Partners as well
to ensure that went well so I think that
was about it
um if anybody has any other points I
know quite a few members of the cabinet
were at um osc which was good whether
they were coming to see my pwns or or or
or what or to talk about depes mode um
we don't know but they might have some
additional points as well but I want to
toise
them um councelor rock wants to ask a
question yeah I want to ask a question
if I may but I'm not trying to put the
chairman in an awkward position because
I know he has a job in another place um
but I I believe uh the fire service are
coming in to um to help the council
understand which was a question we were
uh oops debated at um Council um uh with
your other hat on I don't I don't don't
know if this is permitted but um can you
explain uh the various ways people can
engage with that I I know there are
public sessions uh I've tried to find
how it says first come first served at
the public sessions but you can only
appear to book through event bite so
somebody that is not web enabled not is
not able to do that um have do they have
to come to the council and sit at the
back at the scrutiny committee is that
the only way they can do it or can you
tidy up how people book on on sessions
wherever they are in our big District
please yeah it is the event right um
obviously um we are concerned about
people turning up on the day without um
booking because um capacity issues I
know there's capacity issues at the gr
chore um and we're worried about you
know um so yeah that is the one way of
doing again we've got the online
consultation um um through through the
website and there will be there should
be some information in the libraries
some paper copies of the consultation
and the questionnaire um so if there
isn't but but surely we can give him a
phone number to Ring to say want to book
in I mean that's not beyond the Witter
man is it I will bring David B chairman
I don't think we want to compromise
Council comp in his County Council role
at the moment I I think what we can do
we can work with the County Council so
we can circulate to all elected members
that the forms of consultation and the
engagement as part of this this process
thank you if I come to the every in
scrutiny committee um obviously Council
passing will be chairing that item
because I will be the other side of the
table um but the chairman whichever one
who is will be accepting questions in
advance anyway from um and people can
turn up as well but uh we're trying to
get as much consultation as as possible
but yeah I won't be I won't be cheering
the meeting for that item
thank you very much indeed um just a a
small item before uh we move on uh is
just um I I did submit some written
written evidence um to the um task of
ini about housing um I I I think I've
got the second largest um orbit um
number of orbit houses in my area uh I
haven't been interviewed for anything or
being asked to contribute is there any
um would am I required to you know to um
submit any any information or to um you
know support um the Improvement in that
area I'll get councelor Wally hoggins
she's chairing that part of task and
finish groups on on that
one yes your comments have been really
welcomed as of the comments from other
from other counselors um councelor junid
we're currently waiting for the survey
results to come back from the housing
associations and then it is uh we will
be reporting back and again your
comments will be uh noted within that uh
any member any counselor is allowed to
come to to the task and finish group if
if they wish but I'll make a note of the
fact that you would like to come and
address us give me the dates I do know
whether or not I can get them into my
diary I will do that um because I say I
do have an awful lot of um problems that
arise as a result of the Housing
Association coordination etc etc um had
another one U yesterday that uh uh quite
a lengthy one so I do need to talk to to
somebody moving on then uh because I
don't there's no uh that was um part C
was is just issues arising from that
part D is cabinet committees there were
nothing there's nothing to report then
part e is on block items uh and um these
are all to be approved on block unless a
request has been made to the leader at
the start of the meeting no request has
been made to me at the start of the
meetings so the uh cabinet work program
um is agreed and or noted rather and
part of other matters there
no other matters that have been erased
with me and there's been no urgent
business that's been erased with me so
unless anybody has anything different to
say no I end the meeting at this
point